all right so this is taco
- Unreal Engine lessons learned from
possible my name is Ellen good morning
glad you made it here okay all right so
first off we're gonna talk about what
what the talk is gonna cover I want to
make sure that you know you know what's
coming I'll touch base on Who I am why
am I here just briefly talk of a little
bit about where I work place called
Detroit labs because I think the more I
talk to other developers the more I
realize just how unique my company is
and it's it's not I'm not trying to give
you a sales pitch or anything like that
it's just more to give you some
background knowledge so then when I talk
about how sort of ridiculous this
project is that we worked on you kind of
understand why we even got in that
position in the first place then I will
walk you through the project I'll tell
you what the challenges were again why
we ended up where we were what we faced
and how we solve them and then as sort
of a recap I'll go through the the big
lessons that stood out to me that I've
learned that have already been taking
forward to other projects with me so you
know if you not offer anything you get a
quick run through at the end and then at
the end of course questions and maybe
even some answers if I can always
willing to do that so my name is Ellen I
work at Detroit labs I'm an iOS
developer so keep that in mind coming
from a mobile perspective but I like to
travel usually spend my free time
hanging out with my cats or playing ice
hockey that's a picture of me riding a
camel into the Sahara in Morocco so it's
just sort of that's a little snapshot of
me on most my slides you'll see my
Twitter handle if you have any questions
feel free to tweet them out to me you
know during or after
I don't tweet too often but it's usually
just a recap of all the beers I've drank
so if you but I do respond if you do
have any questions feel free to reach
out to me there I've also placed
business cards on both of the little
like survey tables so if you have a
question you you know need to leave
early anything like that feel free to
email me with anything any questions you
have so as I mentioned I work for a
company called Detroit labs and I would
or based in Detroit in the States we are
a mobile services company we make
primarily mobile apps that we do some
web projects hardware pretty much
anything that excites us that gets us
interesting if a client comes and say
hey we want to do this well we find that
fun and interesting it doesn't matter if
we haven't done it before will typically
say yes and then figure out how we're
going to do it which really speaks to
the confidence that our sales team our
co-founders anybody who's doing that
pitching they have that confidence in
our entire team and so does the team you
know we have a confidence in ourselves
as a company that we can figure out a
solution to whatever problems are
presented to us well we we we have
plenty of technical specialists I tend
to think of us as a company as more
generalists more were problem solvers
which allows us not to be locked into
you know a certain platform or medium in
order to get stuff done we we can figure
out a solution regardless we have a
company culture that cultivates
curiosity so we hire for people that are
want to be continuously learning
expanding their knowledge set and can
and working on their on their skill set
and it's and always expanding what they
know so you're open to new ideas you're
you know you're encouraged to do that
and then
a big big part of that is this
atmosphere that we have that promotes
mutual support and learning so the sense
that you know mistakes are gonna happen
if if we are always learning if we're
always pushing ourselves mistakes are
just part of that deal
and knowing that allows us to trust each
other a lot more you know I'm I will be
more willing to take a big risk say oh
yeah I will take on this new platform or
whatever it is because I know my company
expects a mistakes will happen right
well fix them we'll figure it out so
taking those risks being trusted to take
those risks and knowing that in the end
what we learned from that will benefit
the company we work on a variety of apps
just so you know a little more about my
background work those are some of our
clients based in Detroit so we do a lot
of automotive work but we also do with
the medical work banking apps fast-food
all sorts of things like that so we're
kind of all over the place and that's
just a picture of our one of the floors
in our office space so we we tend to
have different relationships with our
clients in that they come to us with an
idea and we take a lot of ownership of
that idea we're not working in a system
where it's hey do this and we want to
exactly done this way we are often doing
the designing the developers get
involved from an early stage we're part
of the architecture planning and a lot
of times our clients trust us to sort of
ask the questions and figure out exactly
what it is they really want what
problems they want to solve so we have
that freedom to maybe introduce new
technologies or different areas to kind
of push the client forward and open
their minds to new ideas that they maybe
never came to us with so that's the
background on labs
gives you a little bit of an idea just
keep that in the back your mind while
we're talking about the project because
every time I explain this project that
we went through to somebody else they're
like well why didn't you just do it the
easy way there's a lot of reasons but as
we home that was software developers you
can't always do things the easy way
all right so this this crazy project I
work on the impossible
it's the bulk of what we're gonna talk
about today so being a mobile services
company we especially the Apple
developers the iOS developers we always
get together during WWC which is Apple's
developer conference and we'll watch
that together as a company or to lunch
and just see what's new what's new for
developers for Apple and this past year
augmented reality a arcade an augmented
reality framework was introduced and the
demo at WWDC was actually pretty
impressive I don't know if you've seen
it but it was you know they're up on a
stage there's a empty table and they
have an iPad pulling it at the table and
the screen for the iPad is projected up
on the big screen for everybody to see
and once they start the app that empty
tables now populated with like a warzone
there's helicopters flying in people
jumping out of the helicopter stuff
exploding off the table
very impressive graphics really really
cool you know sort of immersive 3d
experience they were walking all the way
around the table showing you all the
angles of the whole thing so that was
cool and one of our co-founders saw that
and was like we should do something with
this let's let's figure out what could
we do and he had an opportunity coming
up to pitch to a large automotive client
that he's always wanted to work with so
when I'm from it's sort of like your
family's with one company or another and
that's where you sit so it's it's you
know his dad's always worked for this
company he's driven all their cars loves
this company so he had an opportunity
for that and he's like you know it would
be great if we could make it a pour you
could put their release in this new car
if you could put that car in your
driveway so you can see it that would be
really fun
so he's like anybody's got who's got
bandwidth who can work on that put that
together just a quick and dirty demo so
we can take it over there a couple of my
co-workers at the time had free time to
to work on it so they just bought a
really low res but 3d model of a car got
it to work in a arcade so it was fun you
know we could put a car right on the
floor in our office you can walk around
it we're like wow this is actually
pretty neat to get this working he took
that to the to the pitch and they loved
it they're like this is great let's I
want to see more so I only got the team
together and that's when I got involved
it's a little nervous because I haven't
done this before right so all right
teams assembled we just know we're
making an AR app but we don't know what
its gonna do so we're gonna figure out
what is this project and there's a lot
of what you would look at especially if
you had more control as red flags you
know you know we tend to work on
projects that we try to be fix goat-face
fixed cost
maybe not fixed time you know if you
that's it's like a mix of those right
you want your best thing and we've got
none of those on this project except for
we have a fixed deadline a very hard and
fast deadline that was fast approaching
so we we had our own personal stretch
goal of you know be really great we're
using this new technology that's in beta
for Apple in the fall they always do the
Apple event where they you know announce
the new iPhone or whatever it is and
they they feature some demos onstage
that would be cool if that was us so we
started getting in touch with Apple
seeing if it was possible we're like
okay well if we do this that means we
have to have something done in about two
months
little scary but okay fine and
eventually that that goal went away
because we realized it wasn't realistic
and not the best thing working actually
working with Apple on it they're like
you know you your clients only going to
get like
30 seconds of stage time so I don't know
if it's worth you guys tearing your hair
out for this but the client had its own
deadline they were launching this
product a new vehicle coming out and
they wanted an app that was going to
sort of have a teaser experience leading
up to the launch and then a big really
immersive AR experience once once they
reviewed the reel the sari revealed the
vehicle so that they was set that was
not moving that was we can't change that
we also didn't have a contract or at
least not signed one there's lots of
talks trying to get one together
there was this project really ran and
handshakes verbal agreements over the
phone and we knew that was a risk and
we're all aware of it and this is one of
those things that's kind of unique you
know not every company not every person
can take this chance but we kind of our
founders were on board saying we know we
we're excited about this we want to work
on it we know we might not get paid for
it we know it could get cancelled any
day there's a lot of risks going into
this but that's fine we want to take
that gamble because we think the odds of
you know winning this contract getting
this contact working with this company
all those things totally totally a win
so ok everybody's on board we're taking
the risk we also had an end product our
app was changing frequently I went from
ok place the car in your driveway to
we're gonna have something with like
seven worlds that come up out of the
table and it spins and the users gonna
pick a world and then it's gonna take
you to that terrain and they're gonna
drop a car that's rain and all this
different stuff right like so we went
from being like it's just like one thing
cool I can do that no problem - oh wow
this is huge right and just kept getting
bigger well we got less time because
that dates not moving and then of being
a high profile product a new car for
this company there's a lot of stress
our team did a really good job of
managing the stress inside our own
project I didn't feel very stressed at
work
I'm catching myself because that's a bit
of a lie but we felt stressed just
because we're like can we do this
you know everything they keep asking for
we've got to make sure we're not over
promising because we know we have to
deliver and so there's a little stress
around that but in general it wasn't too
bad but we could tell that the client
was stressed this is a big launch for
them and they had a lot invested in that
all right so that's some of our
constraints let's add some more so we
know we're making an a our app we're
developers we are not animators or 3d
artists so thankfully the client already
had a company working on their 3d model
and they would do the animations and the
3d worlds for us we just had to pop them
in the app and do the logic for the app
cool but their pipeline required Unreal
Engine which is an open source graphics
engine so that was kind of a new thing
for us that added a lot of questions a
our kit I mean it was beta in Xcode at
the time it was definitely beta and
Unreal Engine but it was that demo I
talked about on the stage with that
battlezone it was unreal engine that
actually partnered with Apple to create
that so well pretty good about that you
know they've got that support but
because it was in beta there was very
little documentation available I mean
this is brand-new technology what we're
working on it there was I don't know a
fair number of people saying like oh
here's air kit built in Xcode we're
putting lamps on tables or whatever it
is there's lots of people trying it out
writing blog posts about it there were
like five people doing it in Unreal
Engine and everybody's just on the
Unreal Engine forums it's it's it was
not what I was used to as far as being
able to look at Stack Overflow and find
an answer or find some answers to cobble
together and figure out a solution
documentation was lacking there was
documentation
for Unreal Engine itself but the a our
kit documentation started out with none
when we first started working on I'm not
kidding you there was zero documentation
for it hey our kit was just like hey
there's a thing it exists or I'm sorry
Unreal Engine that's what they said
they're just like we put this out we put
out on a our kit plugin
. then they put out one very small
tutorial that's it no documentation on
how anything works what each one of
these components does it was just here's
how to get started with a our kit that's
it
and as far as i know last i checked
about a couple weeks ago that's still
that's all that's out there for that on
top of these issues that we are facing
the vendor that we were working with
that was making the 3d models they also
kind of approach the project differently
and that's i mean that's their right
right i said we were willing to take on
that risk of not being paid having the
project cancelled all that kind of stuff
they were not they'd worked with this
client before and they said we're not
starting on this until we have a
contract signed that's fine that's their
prerogative but that made it more
difficult they didn't want to spend any
of their time or their man-hours working
on it or working with us right they're
like well we're not being paid to work
with you right now we're not being paid
to teach you how to use Unreal Engine so
we're in a brand new IDE without this
support system of developers who are
used to using Unreal Engine then there
was the whole fact that when we looked
at what we wanted to do in this project
we wanted to provide in like a native
iOS experience for reasons that I'll get
into in a minute and we're trying to
figure out is that even possible
in Unreal Engine because Unreal Engine
is primarily used for games if you're
building a full-on application in there
it's also used to make like the Dragons
and Game of Thrones so it's it's pretty
hefty if you're not familiar with it but
a lot of the development that happens in
there is is game development barley
and so I mean most of us have at least
seen video games if we don't play video
games they have kind of a different UI
than a standard native iOS app which is
one thing we were considering we wanted
to make this native iOS for a few
reasons
one at the time for augmented reality as
far as the frameworks went that was it
it was only on Apple Android has since
come out with it well there's but at the
time there was only a our kit for Apple
that's all we were gonna do so lots of
other valid reasons for why we wanted to
make sure it was native iOS but that one
really locked us in we didn't have a
choice
another thing we talked about yeah okay
maybe we're not gonna get up on stage at
that Apple event but we could get
featured on the App Store and apples
more likely to do that if we're using
new tech which we were and if it's a
platform exclusive we felt using our
like we're working inside our wheelhouse
we are native iOS developers that's what
the team was composed of that allowed us
to do would allow us to do maximum
custom ability customization for the for
the app and really kind of do whatever
the client wanted right because that's
what we know and the other thing was our
end users for this app we're gonna be
you know anybody who's buying this car
anybody's dreaming of buying this car
they're not necessarily gamers so that
was a big thing that we wanted to kind
of avoid the aesthetic that you get
without inside a game we wanted to make
sure that the app behaved like an iOS
app did you know we want it to be easy
to use and very intuitive to use so it
was a big factor for us all right so we
got some decisions made we got some
constraints laid out time to get to work
on the project we need to figure out
what else don't we know and three big
questions come on
how does a our kit even work in Unreal
Engine how do you how do you get in
augmented reality experience working
there can we go from Unreal Engine to X
code or X code to Unreal Engine because
we primarily code in X code so if we can
avoid doing a whole new project in a
brand new IDE because we're on fixed
time if I'm get all the time in the
world sure I'll learn a new IDE no
problem but we're like how can we get
this done it'll be easiest if we could
write in an IDE write in a platform that
we're used to working in and then just
you know this is wishful thinking pop
over to Unreal Engine fire that up and
give us the AR experience and then okay
back to all the stuff we're used to in
Xcode so is that even possible and then
if that's not possible can we create
some sort of native feel in Unreal
Engine can we mock that up somehow and
in order to accomplish this in the very
tight timeframe we had we split up so
there's three developers on the team
each one of us took a question and we
would touch base very often because this
because we were sort of researching in
different directions we weren't
necessarily committing code it was a lot
of research not a lot of PR reviews and
stuff we want to make sure we avoided
entrenching in those silos we wanted to
make sure we were all on the same page
with what was happening in the app and
so we you know instead of just coming
together at stand up we were coming
together two three times a day to say
it's a here's what I'm here's where I'm
at this is what I'm struggling with this
is what I'm working on this is what I've
discovered and just making sure we're
always keeping that communication open
as well as documenting it as best we
could well then of course this was rough
going if you ever want to feel like
you're a total idiot
start a new project and a brand new IDE
you've never worked on it's I don't know
it's like why don't you know one of the
curses of being a developer you feel
like a genius in an idiot and I don't
know in the span of 20 seconds and then
that repeats right that's our experience
you want to live in the idiot zone for a
while try something brand new that
you're getting paid to do kind of rough
so plenty of beer on hand so my area
while I was working on this I took the
question of alright how do we get a our
kit working in Unreal Engine there's an
AR kit plug-in I never worked in Unreal
Engine before if you haven't ever even
seen this is this is an example of the
IDE I think it's really gross also if
you want to but no no no judge that is
judging so I can't say no judging but
but you know everything that it's
different ends up being something you
know you're kind of afraid you don't
like you're not used to it
I'll tell you what though you ever want
to like love your much hated IDE
everybody hates Xcode I could stand up
here and talk for hours about all the
problems with Xcode this made me love
Xcode I was so happy to go back to that
but my my challenge was to figure out
how to get Erica twerking in there so
Unreal Engine themselves support the AR
kit plug-in which is good and bad
most other plugins that they have our
third-party and that means if that third
party's great and on top of their stuff
there's tons of documentation it's easy
to use and it's fantastic also means you
know it's open source in third party so
maybe they've dropped off the face of
the earth and that plugin hasn't been
supported in two years again
Unreal Engine just put out their plug-in
and they're like yep it's there good
luck
so that led to a lot of issues to trying
to figure out how this even works when
we first started working with it we
actually had to launch Unreal Engine
from source because a our cube that was
the only way erica plugin was available
thankfully that a few weeks in they made
it available in a public beta as I
mentioned learning a new IDE is
incredibly tricky and can be really
frustrating
one thing that I noticed in Unreal
Engine was that the feedback as a
developer was wasn't really there or not
in a way I expected there was a
console.log but sometimes it took 20
seconds after clicking to launch it to
my phone before I got anything and so I
didn't know well is it frozen because
this was you know we're working in beta
it was freezing and crashing three or
four times a day at a minimum so is it
frozen this time or is it running and I
just have to wait it out and then it
pops up and says yes it's running so the
the silent failures you would get the
very quiet failures you get ended up
making it a very stressful situation in
the end I was able to place I ended up
using a banana on a platform so any
surface I could find I could place a
banana there I used a banana because
we'd worked with the vendor and we said
hey listen can you just give us anything
like I know you make dragons for Game of
Thrones just give us a tree like we
don't need a dragon give us something we
can put in the world so we can practice
this because we are not 3d artists just
give us something to work with give us a
demo file so I'm like sure no problem
I'll have you know Bob send you
something over I get an email from Bob
okay great download it we just can't get
it working and we're like this is a lot
that's a lot you know we asked for like
a tree and we've got a forest they sent
us an entire forest don't really seems
like a lot well going back and forth
with them okay we can't we can't get it
opening what are we doing wrong you know
I mean part of this is just like we
don't know you know like can you imagine
trying to get a project somebody sent
you open and your ID a ID and you've
never touched it before you've never
seen that you don't know all the setups
all the things you got to do to get
something going so we're like okay you
know yeah I'm sure it's us you guys know
what you're doing what's going on with
him finally they're in our office when
they were like could you give us five
minutes just get this open for us okay
he looks at it he's like oh this is what
they sent you well we had asked for was
a tree because we wanted something we
you know we said
we're gonna figure out how many Polly's
we can have how what can the phone
actually handle like like I said this
can make dragons but we got to run this
on an iPhone so what can the phone
handle as far as an intense 3d
experience we're like all right I know
like ten thousand works no problem so
send us something around there they sent
us something with three hundred thousand
Polly's and he's like this is why it's
not you know it's not working okay I'll
send you something new in the meantime I
was able to do just a basic Unreal
Engine demo learned how to make banana
so I was able to place bananas all over
the place so you've never seen a group
developer so excited about bananas
so that was one little mini success next
lay my poor coworker he's like okay I've
dug into the source code I've dug into
the documentation trying to figure out
how we can go from Unreal Engine tax
code or vice versa because Unreal Engine
on the backend is C++ so we're like okay
you know Swift's probably out of the
question
objective-c maybe but we could
definitely do objective C++ we could
figure that one out and hey if that's if
we got a right objective C++ fine but as
long as we can get working in Xcode
where we can get code completion and all
that kind of stuff that would that would
be awesome all right so he's like you
know digging through this and
theoretically I think if we launch Yui
we could interrupt those lifecycle
methods that are being called because it
actually hooks into those and interrupt
those launch our own thing sort of
background Unreal Engine launch well the
screens we had built in Xcode and then
when the user is like oh ya know take me
to the air thing we just dismissed that
screen and and unpause the Unreal Engine
in the background it's there it's just
hanging out ready to go
he's like theoretically that should work
everything I'm seeing I think we can do
it I don't know how
but all the stuffs there all the calls
are there we should be able to do it all
right so we go to the Google machine and
we're like has anybody done this before
what one no there's I don't know what
probably phone feels like hundreds but
really truthfully probably twenty thirty
people saying we tried you know can you
do this other people want to do this can
you do this no you can't do it we've
tried you can't do it it's impossible
people from Epic Games unlike the people
that make Unreal Engine there on their
floor I'm saying now you can't do it
they're like maybe you could but it's
not worth it and it won't actually work
and I'm like then you can't I don't know
so no just everywhere we looked totally
impossible not gonna happen until one
day we find a forum post one line so
yeah actually we were able to do it but
it's really complicated . you know it'd
have been really nice this is how we did
it or even like maybe not an in-depth
thing but just like yeah look here like
some bread crumb we got nothing
except for this ray of light that it is
possible right we're like wait a second
somebody did it they might be lying but
supposedly they did it and we think it's
possible so that gave that gave my
coworker a bit of a push to say okay you
know these people figured it out I can
figure it out and sure enough he was
able to do it pretty much like I laid
out and if if you want to see like
in-depth technical description of
exactly how he did it
there's a blog series that we worked on
together that covers how we did this
[Music]
it's not easy it's not straightforward
if I explained it all to you up here it
takes me a couple hours but it's on the
Detroit labs blog I'm happy to email it
to you if you're very interested in
so he got it he's you know we could not
believe it that we got this were like
yeah it was great and then few days
later projects cancelled no joke we
spent haha jeez two three months working
on this all these struggles all these
like and we finally get something that
feels like success like we figured out
I'm telling me every day we walked into
work going like I don't know if we can
ever do this you know I like I've never
had that kind of doubt we would face
each other and say I'd you know we have
a deadline we've promised this I don't
know if we can actually do it but we got
to figure it out all right like for now
I'm gonna keep working on and figure it
out so we figured it out and then they
cancelled the project which we knew was
a risk all along
and a big thing for us cuz it was it was
a mixed emotion finding out the project
was canceled what kind of like a huge
weight off our shoulders for sure but at
the same time it was like man what was
all this for what do we learn what do we
take from this and so what did we learn
part of the part of it is we learned
that strategy is vital we've got a small
team strict strict deadlines short time
span to get everything done so we did
that divide and conquer but if you're
gonna divide and conquer which I mean
that's how we divvy up a lot of work
right like everybody takes a card or
however you work but you you're usually
not working on the exact same piece of
code okay but how does that knowledge
share happen how do you make sure that
you're communicating and that stuff is
being properly documented so people can
be on board it and so one thing we did
was look at our strengths divvied up the
work based on the strengths so we could
get it done in the most timeless manner
and then deliberately set out a plan to
make sure we were documenting
whatever that was so we would for two of
us actually I think even the third guy
did it a similar way we would take notes
and I did handwritten notes my friend
was taking hers on her iPad we're doing
notes and then every day taking time to
write up those notes and then saying
okay what does this mean because the
first week or two I would not take notes
and then be like I've done this four
times now I have to redo it every time
because I can't remember the process
because it's all new and I'm learning so
much new information at once so take the
notes take the time to write it up and
then have that commitment on the team to
do that as well another big thing for us
was the the realization that you really
need to be a scholar you need to be a
student of your craft in this situation
we were not able to just go to stack
overflow we weren't able to just Google
and answer or cobble together answers
from documentation very quickly this was
doing something that's never been done
before and tell you ninety ninety five
percent of the work I've done previously
I've been able to at least Google enough
resources to get me a solution right and
this I couldn't even get the resources
we had to really dig deep I I had never
had the experience of having to you know
you can't just command F in here in the
docs in the manual or whatever it is to
find what you're looking for you've got
a really dig deep spend time go through
each line of the code look at the source
code figure out how it's working
basically deconstruct and reconstruct it
so it was it was a new level of learning
for me especially you know we do custom
apps but generally I'm doing something
that's been done before and I think if
we want to push ourselves to do
something brand new to do something
cutting-edge then you have to be willing
to put in that time and energy and I
mean I fully admit it I'm one of those
Millennials with a
Nats attention span so this was it was
tricky it was tough to kind of hone and
polish that another thing I've taken
forward that I'm using on a current
project that let's say I've been on for
three months now our end user has
changed three times in the past two
weeks it's always changing we're just
like we I feel like we're further behind
than where I was when we started the
project you know so this phrase
separately it's kind of a the Marines
use it as like a play on their
simplified Ellis but it just means
always flexible and it's the idea of one
not getting hung up on things you can't
control so we had all those constraints
you know the vendor doesn't want to work
with us or doesn't want to work how we
want to work we're stuck using Unreal
Engine the designs keep changing you
know I can't change any of that
there's going to be rework
love to avoid it but if having to do
rework is something that really
frustrates you makes you want to flip
your table you have to find a way to
just embrace it one one thing I remember
is that hey look I'm being paid to write
code right now I love writing code this
is fantastic
does it suck to write the same code
again yeah of course it does but I'm
still I'm still getting paid to do what
I love right today might be tough but
tomorrow I'll be better so kind of
enforcing those principles being
flexible of don't sweat the small stuff
is the best you can don't sweat the
stuff you can't control because as we
know there's tons of stuff on our
projects we can't control
this is a big one for me and you can
look at it many different ways and I'll
tell you how this hit home for me so
throughout the project I had this theory
that I think we could do this in Xcode I
think we could do this entirely in Xcode
if I could just get our vendor to give
us a demo file of what they would like
what we'd be receiving from them if I
can get that and I can figure out how to
get that in Xcode get that running and
kind of prove that we could do this in
Xcode though and we don't have to worry
about going back and forth we don't have
to worry about trying to make a native
experience inside Unreal Engine I think
we can do this and I've asked the vendor
they're like no no no for the quality of
the the graphics you got to do you got
to use the engine okay a couple weeks go
by and I'm like yeah I really it's kind
of bugging me I really think we could do
this no no I can't do it and at the end
of the project after it was cancelled
our our founders had us just say hey
like keep working on it right now while
we figure out what projects you're going
to next make it all in Xcode see what we
can do create like a proof of concept we
can shop around as a demo to other
clients okay it turns out yeah we
probably could have done it all in Xcode
I'm not personally I'm not somebody that
would say I told you so but what made me
uncomfortable about this situation is I
don't ever want to be in the position to
be able to say I told you so
and what I mean by that is if this
bugged me enough that I was still
thinking about it like me like I called
it I know that was gonna happen why
didn't I take it could I take two hours
two hours of my time to prove myself
right or wrong it wouldn't have bugged
me for all those weeks probably the
amount of time I spent bringing it up
over the course of the weeks that would
have been enough time to prove out my
concept and in fact because I turned out
to be right it could have saved my team
with a bunch of time and what I got from
this and what I want you didn't know for
this is like have the strength in your
conviction
and own it so if something's gonna bug
you like this like no one else cared
right like that I mentioned it they're
not thinking about that now but I was
like man why didn't I why don't I have
to strengthen my conventions til he's
proved myself right or wrong I don't
mind being wrong I mean we're wrong all
the time
right I DS tell us we're wrong all the
time we're used to that so it's not
enough to be right you know you gotta be
right and have people listen to you and
that doesn't mean shout it to the
rooftops people aren't listening then
get the proof of concept figure it out
find a way to prove it and don't be a
jerk about it that one's kind of obvious
I don't like I don't wanna sit up here
me like I wasn't a jerk about it but
it's it's more figure out a way to
communicate it if they're not listening
figure out a way to communicate maybe
it's approaching it from a different way
having that proof of concept but avoid
putting yourself in a position that yeah
I totally called it if you'd listened to
me like we would have saved two weeks of
our time so that helps no one being in
that position a big thing I've touched
on already is the documentation I talked
about how we were taking notes and
taking the time we had a teen commitment
to write up our notes put that
documentation together and in a way that
everybody could read it it would be
there for anybody that was jumping on
the project are our team's tend to we
stay together by project but every once
in a while people roll off roll on and
you don't know who's going to be looking
at your code six months from now
heck you might take six months and go
back on it so take care of yourself take
care of your future teammates by
documenting what you're doing and even
more importantly for us was to share
what we learned like I said we had this
feeling of what did we do all this for
so we spent a couple weeks afterwards we
put together their blog series that's up
on the Detroit labs blog because we're
like we're gonna provide that
documentation
that we wished we would add when we were
working on this project you know we
didn't we didn't complete it right but
we were able to at least solve a lot of
those problems and if we can save even
one person that time in the future so
yeah it's possible
and here's how you do it or at least
here's how we did it then I feel like
that's valuable right then we all that
time we spent learning isn't lost we're
gonna share it with people and then I'm
up here right I was at a conference last
week I did a workshop on how to get
started with a ARCA in Unreal Engine I'm
sharing my knowledge as best I can with
my community to try to give back because
I don't know to me it's like what what's
what good is it if I'm the only one that
knows about it right and if you find
anything valuable then that's a plus the
last big thing for me was that the
impossible probably isn't it probably is
possible and in fact that you know I
talked to people about this and we're
like at well and especially in software
nothing's impossible how much time and
money do you have right if you've got
limitless time and money you probably
figure thing isn't how we put somebody
on the moon you know that was impossible
so it may not be possible with the
constraints that you have but if you're
passionate if you you know if you remove
those constraints if you've got the time
and the money you figure it out and a
big thing for me was to realize like
I'll tell you what I was a doubter of my
coworker who said I think we can go back
and forth and I'm like you'll know
you'll never figure that I don't even
know how to figure that out I mean
obviously I don't but like how could
anybody figure that out and he did I'm
like you know that's amazing the he was
able to dive deep dig in and figure out
how to get those two very different
pieces of software talking together and
working together and it reminds me not
to get stuck in a rut so to keep a broad
perspective on what's possible on a
project and I don't know it was kind of
inspiring to me to see what my
co-workers are capable of and realized
like well typically I mean I've turned
him face like we're not that different
he's got a few years on me as far as
experience goes but we're not that
different so I could figure that out too
which is like really amazing a very
powerful knowledge and so take that time
if you see something if you're lucky
enough to see somebody do the impossible
or you recognize something like that
happening I mean we see new software
coming out all the time that it's it's
really impressive stuff there's nothing
stopping you from doing that too if you
care about it so that's the end of my
ramblings I'm happy to take questions I
did just want to remind you that I have
business cards at the back if you have
questions please feel free to reach out
to me even if just you want the links to
the blog post if you're a glutton for
punishment and want to play around with
going from Unreal Engine to Xcode you're
more than welcome to reach out to me
about that anybody have any questions I
have a question did you have a chance to
compare the apples or IR framework to
unreal capabilities in terms of that and
how does it compare which one would you
choose and why
for what kind of development for AR em
both like AR versus Unreal Engine okay
we we did compare a bit and one of the
things that I realized was the
difference was and in fact we were kind
of leaning towards this way near the end
of the project is if we want to do
something huge
really high-quality maybe F we've got
the hardware that can handle it
right so if I'm doing iPhone or iOS
development maybe we can get a souped-up
iPad that can handle something really
intense and really big that will have
side loaded but when we're talking about
creating something that's got to go in
the App Store that people are gonna have
to download hopefully not over Wi-Fi
again they were this is gonna be at a
big event like sort of conference Wi-Fi
so yeah definitely not downloading stuff
over Wi-Fi we all know how great
conference Wi-Fi is and on their iPhones
and we wanted this to work I want to say
Eric it works on anything seven up for
iPhones and you had to be on iOS 11 so
that means you're kind of limited to the
hardware and we we had talked about ok
for the big demo on stage for the big
reveal we do something in Unreal Engine
we do a big experience that way but for
what we're gonna put in the App Store
for everyday use on an iPhone we could
have done all of that development in
Xcode because otherwise it was going to
be just too much you know you needed the
right tool for the right medication any
other questions
well thanks for joining me oh yeah sorry
but I guess this is an iOS developer you
don't touch the Android stuff much I
just wondering how it compares to a okay
if there's many differences I haven't
personally a few my co-workers have
started playing with it but as far as I
know I don't think like I think it's the
Android developers that have played with
it so they probably don't have too much
to compare but the the notes I've seen
from the outset it's just that similar
capabilities yeah all right thanks for
joining me this morning I ate it have a
great rest of your day
[Applause]